Je connais un sixième homme stressant ouais ouais
ouais hein
mélange
bonne nuit cher
sable aime Deadpool a été observé
Apprendi boo-yah mme.  provo sassetti mais
Suarez ricola ofet sambito messy tipo
food anonyme mask Ursa same at nawet
soiree gossamer lat I second hein si
merveilleuse surprise tu sais parce que
personne ne te dit que tu étais surpris
c'est incroyable Deadpool est un film que
j'essaie de m'avoir depuis 11  ans et il y a
environ un an et demi, nos
images de test que nous avons tournées ont fui
accidentellement sur Internet et la
prochaine chose que nous avons su, nous avons obtenu le feu vert
du film et je ne
peux toujours pas croire que je me tiens
ici devant  vous, j'aimerais pouvoir
vous montrer tout le film ce soir,
tout est très heureux, mais ils ne me laisseront
pas faire ça, alors j'allais absolument
époustoufler vos gars si vous êtes un
loup mort et que vous allez juste exploser votre
attention si de votre côté de cet enclos
vous avez dit que je pouvais venir quand je suis à la maison
ouais c'est complètement différent ouais je
veux dire tout d'abord les films classés R
ce qui est très inhabituel pour tout type de
caractère moral d'être classé R donc il y a
g  être un peu d'humour et de
violence que vous ne verriez jamais
dans un film de Captain America ou tout autre
type de film de super-héros et je suis un grand
fan de films de super-héros, je suis un fan de tous les
super-héros et vous le savez  faire
venir ce personnage en ce moment
est en fait parfait parce que nous sommes
debout, c'est essentiellement ce que je pense que l'
apocalypse de super-héros il y a tellement de
films de super-héros à venir et je pense que
Deadpool est en quelque sorte le film
parfait au moment idéal et je '  J'ai hâte
que vous les gars vous voyiez en selfie avec
ces gars
ouais ouais ouais